mélanie joly que l'on connaît évidemment
très très bien dans la grande région de
montréal
donc finalement madame joly c'est c'est
mieux que la mer ils m'ont rien vous
allez aller à participer au gouvernement
libéral à ottawa mais ça me fait plaisir
d'avoir eu la confiance des gens jeunes
s'écarter ville et d'avoir lancé un
message extrêmement clair à monsieur
harper que j'entendais madame est un
petit peu plus tard let's kick back
country faire en sorte que le canada
devienne progresser si ça va passer par
un gouvernement trudeau et je suis
content de pouvoir en faire partie vous
voyez comme moi que les libéraux bay
lundi dans l'atlantique c'est un c'est
un raz de marée au québec
très très bon score faut remonter pas
mal d'années en arrière pour voir les
libéraux en force au québec comme ça à
quoi vous attribuer ce grand succès de
la soirée
écoutez je pense que monsieur trouve dos
au fine excellente campagne je pense
également que nous avions un plan de
match extrêmement progressiste que ce
charme et les québécois qui étaient
proches des valeurs des québécois avec
une équipe aussi de nouvelle génération
et donc le parti libéral au cours des
dernières années ont fait on a pris nos
erreurs et et voilà pourquoi on a rebâti
le parti de la base et je suis très
contente qu avec tous les bénévoles qui
ont été impliqués ici en s'écarter ville
comme ailleurs qu'on était capable de
rebâtir la crédibilité mais aussi
redonner confiance aux québécois et à
terme s'imposer comme l'alternative
progressiste au québec et je laisse par
ailleurs au canada
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui selon vous
va changer le plus rapidement qu est-ce
que les gens qui nous écoutent la caisse
qui sera le plus apparent selon vous
dans le premier gouvernement de justesse
d'abord il ya une parité hommes femmes
ce qui vous aide un peu j'imagine mais
qu'est ce qui va être le plus apparent
mais je pense que les priorités le temps
l'approché leadership inclusif de
monsieur trudeau souvent vous savez on a
déploré autant dans les municipalités
que dans les provinces qu'il n'y avait
pas de rencontre entre le premier
ministre et les maires et premiers
ministres des provinces
alors monsieur trudeau l'a déjà dit il
allait faire en sorte de faire un
fédéralisme de utiliser la proche du
fédéralisme inclusif du fédéralisme de
collaboration et je pense que ça ça va
être vraiment clé et vous savez
rapidement au cours des prochains mois
les prochaines semaines de la conférence
de paris qui arrivent déjà et donc que
le canada sur investissent dans la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
elle se meut suis trop doux l'a dit et
on entendu beaucoup parler sur le
terrain
alors je pense que ça va faire partie
notamment des priorités dont je faisais
mention qui fait plutôt très bien mais
mélanie joly
félicitations pour votre victoire
lentilles car tu venir si on aura
l'occasion de reparler
je vous demanderai pas parce que je
connais la réponse si vous voulez être
ministre ça vous allez me dire que ton
premier ministre a décidé alors on verra
au cours des prochaines semaines
j'ajouterai également que monsieur
trudeau aura l'embarras du choix parce
qu'il a une extraordinaire équipe avec
lui merci mélanie joly au revoir à la
prophétie au revoir